we begin tonight with our top story a
Hannity watch featuring what is a sad
and scary radicalization of the
Democratic Party everybody should be
concerned now remember just a few
decades ago there were racist
anti-semites bigots well you think back
Civil Rights Act Voting Rights Act and
some of the past history the Democratic
Party we've outlined that history in
fact congressional Democrats
overwhelmingly voted against the 64
Civil Rights Act 112 Democrats voting
against it including Al Gore's father
the 1965 Voting Rights Act was largely
opposed by Democrats whopping 770
Democratic lawmakers opposing those
important protections for minorities in
America and one of the longest-serving
dendup democratic rock stars in the US
Senate was a former Klansmen somebody
that Hillary Clinton has mentioned as
her mentor Robert Byrd now unfortunately
tonight the more things change sadly
we're beginning to see the more they
stay the same
we have freshman congresswoman Omar who
has now exposed her party's all to cozy
relationship with virulent anti-semitism
constantly pushing anti Israeli
conspiracy theories she called the
world's only Jewish state evil
speculated that its citizens were
hypnotizing the world
she's continuously uses anti-semitic
well characterizations about Jewish
people and money and Jewish do loyalty
to Israel but as of tonight
congresswoman Omar has faced zero
consequences for her blatant and
constant display of anti-semitism and
remains on the important foreign affairs
committee now we have 12 pro-israel Pro
Jewish organizations have called on
Speaker Pelosi to remove Omar from that
committee but that's not going to happen
Pelosi is now throwing those groups
right under the bus and making the
lamest of excuses for her anti-semitic
colleague let's take a look when you
cross that threshold into Congress your
words weigh much more than when you're
shouting at somebody outside and I feel
confident that her words were not based
on any anti-semitic at
- but that she didn't have a full
appreciation of how they landed on other
people where this these words have a
history and a cultural impact that may
have been unknown to her
I'm sure speaker Pelosi will give the
same considerations to Republicans when
they say similar things god forbid or
she'll make excuses for anybody now
Pelosi sadly is not the only Democrat
giving cover to congresswoman Omar the
chairman of the Foreign Affairs
Committee is also refusing to take the
necessary action against the anti-semite
on his committee take a look at what
point do you say to her congressman Omar
look you're not on this committee
anymore you strip her of your seat are
you close to that or at that point no I
I'm not close to it I first of all it's
not up to me this is done by the the
leadership I don't know that that would
do anything except exacerbate the
situation even more I'm looking to get
rid of anti-semitism not looking to
punish anybody biggest problem here is
this keeps happening
with congressman Omar again and again
and believe it or not it gets worse
Democratic majority whip james Clyburn
actually saying to the hill that Omar's
life experiences weigh quote more
personal than the children of Holocaust
survivors so everyone should give her a
break all right well I'm not sure if
most Americans agree with that analogy
we did lose six million Jewish souls
were slaughtered in the Holocaust and
that's not all many 20 20 presidential
candidates they are also supporting Omar
including Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris
Elizabeth Warren so too are many other
prominent Democrats on Capitol Hill
we've got the tape take a look I think
it's just part of a learning process
that we have is as a country frankly
they're different perspectives my
perspective is that her comments were
inappropriate about that she has
apologized and that we should move on
I'm looking to get rid of anti-semitism
not looking to punish anybody Johan Omar
is a refugee from Somalia she comes from
a different culture she has things to
learn she apologizes again and again and
again
now this is really now the party of
literally accepting what is pretty
varial and anti-semitism bigotry and
perhaps most alarming and most telling
part of this entire scandal is that a
House Resolution that was to condemn
anti-semitism it didn't have enough
Democratic support to even bring it to a
vote because they knew wouldn't pass
well that was until speaker Pelosi
allowed congresswoman Omar access to
literally help in the editing of the new
resolution you can't make this up and it
doesn't mention her name and this bill
condemned pretty much every horrible
group of people white supremacist neo
Nazis KKK white supremacist who murdered
nine African Americans in 2015
condemning bigotry against Muslims
Hindus Sikhs and yet also condemned
anti-semitism didn't mention her name
not once now the very reason why this
bill this condemnation was to be written
in the first place it also made no
mention of congresswoman Talib who wrote
a column for Louis Farrakhan's
racist and anti-semitic newspaper it
also made no mentions of the various
Democrats who associate with Linda
Sarsour another variant anti-semite she
has publicly supported Sharia law and
female genital mutilation like twenty20
contenders Kirsten Gillibrand Bernie
Sanders Kirsten Gillibrand was on stage
with Sarsour Democratic congressman ted
Lieu and then of course representatives
Acacio Cortes and to leave and so many
more where is the moral simple strength
to just stand up to this bigotry where's
Nancy Pelosi now there's a reason why
she's acted in this way and the truth
and the reality is she really knows deep
down in her heart she is no longer
Speaker
she lives in complete fear and panic and
is totally and completely controlled by
this fringe radical socialist
anti-semitic elements in her party she
knows that if she doesn't accommodate
their extreme wins in this case of
congresswoman Omar Talley bokura kasnia
Cortes she will be overthrown from that
all-important position so tonight Nancy
Pelosi is merely the Speaker of the
House and name only the radicals
pulling the strings and it's a pretty
scary picture and today we learned that
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortez
has been hit with a brand-new complaint
now this time over her boyfriend's email
account now the ethics complaint alleges
that Acacio Cortez actually obtained an
official mail.house.gov email address
for a boyfriend by falsely designating
him a staff member this is now the third
recent complaint filed against Acacio
Cortez she also received two FEC
complaints including one accusing her of
illegally funneling thousands and
thousands of dollars in campaign funds
to her boyfriend another alleging that
her campaign manager improperly funneled
funneled nearly a million dollars from
the campaign to private business that
one in particular but they're all
extremely serious issues that could
result in charges as it relates to
campaign violations that's if we have
equal justice under the law and
according to reports Acacio Cortez may
soon face even more legal trouble with
an impending ethics complaint
surrounding the improper literally
commingling of campaign and government
social media accounts in order to raise
money like every other good socialist
she appears to be pretty corrupt to the
core especially now with money involved
and tonight she represents everything
that is wrong with this new radical
extreme Democratic Socialist Party a
party that is excusing their own bigotry
and anti-semitism a party that is
pushing the most radical socialist
economic policies that will guarantee
America spirals into a depression it's
that serious a party that has gone so
far to the left
they won't even hold the debate on the
Fox News Channel by the way I won't be
hosting don't worry let not your hearts
be troubled a pretty gutless move by
Democrats and yesterday President Trump
he responded on Twitter writing quote
Democrat just Democrats just blocked at
Fox News from holding a debate good and
I think I'll do the same with the fake
news networks and the radical left
Democrats in the general election
debates well that makes sense given that
every single second of every 24 hour day
these other networks are totally
completely dedicated to one thing and
one thing only trashing smearing
besmirching and destroy
President Trump and anyone that likes
him and I'm sure these networks would
love to hold future Republican debates
despite of course constantly
dehumanizing and lying about President
Trump and never admitting it in reality
we know that 2020 Democrats they're just
too afraid to face real questions from
fair and balanced journalists here on
the Fox News Channel in our news
division journalists who don't buy into
the conspiracy theories and fake news
that will last fair and tough questions
you know what they're not in the tank
like CNN and MSNBC on this network we
distinguish opinion and news obviously I
am a talk show host and I've explained
that job for all the people that want to
listen they don't seem to understand
what it is we do journalists who won't
feed questions to their favorite
candidates ahead of time remember CNN
did that for Hillary Clinton number in
2016 Hillary Clinton's campaign totally
ignored huge blocks of voters that she
considered deplorable the rest is
history
maybe this radical crop of 20/20
Democrats maybe they'll learn from her
mistakes I tend to doubt it okay tonight
before we get to our guests we have an
important update Hannity watch on
Mulder's witch-hunt well today Paul
Manafort was sentenced to 47 months in
prison now that's just shy of four years
now this is for tax fraud bank fraud
other crimes not at all as the judge
pointed out in very strong terms today
nothing related to Trump Russia
collusion nothing to even do with the
time that manna fort worked for Trump
which was I think maybe a hundred days
now Madoff or could have been sentenced
to 19 to 24 years if Muller got his way
obviously they wanted him to die in
prison for cheating on his taxes and
lying on loan applications by the way
free advice haiya taxes the federal
judge called those guys on guidelines
excessive the judge has also gone out of
his way reminding people this case has
nothing whatsoever to do with the Trump
campaign and Russia collusion this is a
witch hunt remember the judge judge
Ellis in this case had said oh they want
to put the screws to man afford so he'll
start to sing or compose we know what
this is all about otherwise we wouldn't
be here all true and now four years in
jail for Manta for
now that's not stopping by the way the
mainstream hate Trump media mob from
taking a joyous victory lap by the way
when is Hillary going to be charged take
a look it's sort of like when they wield
Hannibal Lecter and you know on that
gurney in in Silence of the Lambs I have
very little sympathy for Paul Manafort
at this point you impeach if it's the
only option for protecting the country
from someone you know as campaign
chairman not working in the American
interest his days of $10,000 suits are
over no matter how this plays out
he's going to prison for some period of
time most likely a long time Paul man
affords case and even Michael cones case
pay your taxes and if filling out a loan
application don't lie
good advice obey the laws for years the
mainstream media breathlessly reporting
conspiracy theories about Trump stealing
the election with Russia and there was
collusion they told you Russia was
blackmailing Trump they reported about
trips to Prague that never happened
remember they reported that Donald Trump
had two hookers in his suite at the Ritz
Carlton urinating on his bed it never
happened as so many other lies were told
by the media but they're celebrating the
sentencing of a 69 year old man over
charges that had absolutely zero to do
with President Trump or his campaign and
they take apparently great joy in all of
this we'll have more on this later in
the program